what is the greatest cake that's amazing
PewDiePie cakes is that Anthony that's
Smosh Anthony death
what are you get off my cake Smosh
Anthony oh my god
why is this a thing why why is this a
thing and why did no one tell me that
there's one cake to rule them all one
cake to master the others
[Music]
hello bro brofist no I've never felt so
straight he's never felt so straight
I've never felt so gay like I'm gonna
take your favorite youtuber and I'm
gonna turn them edible and you guys this
episode is an edible PewDiePie
brofist this guy is like Joey Graceffa
ate himself I can't six six years of
breakfast I'm done no more breakfast
this guy ruined it
so without further ado let's turn
cutie-pie edible I have never felt more
uncomfortable in my life yeah let's get
to the damn cake I trimmed up the cake
to make him more even though I put some
frosting on it and then I put the other
layer on top of that and somehow an ass
crack formed and I loved it because it
reminded me of my what the [ __ ] that
cake reminded you of your are you saying
my face remind you of your ass that's
what they asked you are you just to say
that you're fine you're not really fun I
keep getting triggered I just keep
getting triggered you can't watch
anything so first I filled in the crack
goodbye ass crack oh and then I added in
like a nose and a forehead and all the
basic structures of the human anatomy
besides private parts and [ __ ] like that
everything on a face unless if your face
has a dick on it thanks for not putting
a dick in my face I appreciate that
thank you very much put that right on to
the cake form that I made and it looks
like a head like look at that like it's
forming into a creepy doll head
his name is Felix Arvid Ulf Kjellberg
that was really good
that was very impressive as almost like
my own dad said it what the [ __ ] is this
cake oh my god okay so my edible
PewDiePie it's finished it turned out
kind of terrifying kind of terrifying
and nevermind okay that is a
great-looking cake you know what that is
a really good-looking cake I don't know
what to think
I don't want to offend no I'm not
offended why would you think that
I would be if that it's an accurate cake
I don't think anyone can argue with that
that's an accurate depiction of me as a
cake okay oh he went for it great well
the folks say that is disgusting
subscriber those regional arias and
funny but I also think that it's because
he's delicious I'm delicious
we need to retrieve this technology we
could harvest it use it for the greater
good of mankind I will bake this cake
and this cake will take over my channel
let's join
[Music]
look at me I got the costume and
everything that's funny right now I made
these cakes myself I made two of them
he's gonna be at the base strength up
the face right I think you did this I'm
just gonna assume this is my face might
be a delicious cake I know you never
know if it's gonna Michael you want to
buy no yeah then you made the face right
but he mixed it with laying you took a
little bit of this and he mixed it in
with like this this is my first deal
would you d why I do DIY and I really
hope it will go well for that big enough
for you to want bigger it's that I like
not big enough
you know I'm self-conscious about my
nose yeah it's big okay yeah
is that better for you no all right it's
not that big how's that for a start
all right this is gonna be my spoon now
you want to grab your stick with that I
don't know any like English dictionary
we're fumbling this is gonna be my face
is it gay to eat yourself
[Music]
I'm not saying it's wrong okay oh no I
didn't say was wrong I just said is a
game why don't you have [ __ ] flour
I'm sick everyone is flour using
pancakes
you don't make pancakes
don't touch it what is my Z this is not
how you do it you think this is okay
okay well I think we got something going
here
Oh feels good - it feels like touching a
face oh I imagine this is not blind
people do it
you know what I mean I'm a little roust
I'm alone Rudy now we cut this [ __ ] open
oh [ __ ]
you don't have spaghetti do you you have
noodles no why do you have no food
who doesn't have spaghetti okay fine
fine yeah looks pretty good what do you
think this is my hair's well your boy
like I saw his cake and I thought hey
there's there's no way I can make an
uglier cake than his cake oh wow okay
all right definitely good idea put those
there I think I'm sorry anything I feel
pretty confident like acne I don't even
have a Cooking Channel and I can do it
better than the pros if you didn't have
noodles now this is the beard hey that's
[Music]
it's a very good cake sometimes you do
really you really go higher than in your
expectations and this is definitely not
one of those times
Michael you're licking your lips no you
can't wait what do you want what area do
you want to miss baby you want that do
you want this part that's good this is
been cooking with beautify thank you so
much for this amazing tutorial now over
to you prettify all right well I hope
you enjoyed that video if you did go
check out Timmy tomato was that his name
Timmy tomato really funny dude I'm
really happy made this video so check
them out if you're interested in cakes
guess he's making more cakes huh no one
can stop him I'm not doing the brofist
anymore Timmy tomato why don't you take
it over thank you very much get it fast
as much information as possible
go you should watch cowspiracy because
it's a very good thing to watch very
gory
I don't recommend watching it but just
understand will you repeat that
you should watch cowspiracy because it's
a very good thing to watch but it's very
gory so I don't recommend watching it
[Music]
damn that's good